here comes the bachelor all dressed and
my nice jacket I only wear for special
event security on fire thank you my
friend and gentlemen welcome to my
bachelor party this is the elite party
squad that is assuming the captain is
ready to let loose captain I don't think
so
I want you guys to think of me as one of
the boys so tonight I'll be swapping out
my captain's hat for my Kangol hat call
me Raymond okay Raymond in the can go
ahead I will definitely call you Raymond
Raymond to the can go ahead ladies and
gentlemen we are gathered here today to
answer an age-old question right
what's Amy's deal she's single no we're
dating come on the question is who here
does the best impression of captain
Raymond Holt you'll be judged on voice
body language and overall lack of flair
everyone will perform the same scenario
captain Holt eating a marshmallow for
the very first time let the whole table
begin
what is this glutinous monstrosity
before me sugar and this is quite sweet
that's your Holt impression I can hear
him doing that looks like a sticky
pillow I don't care for it classical
music what's going on here what are you
doing
captain Hey nothing just eating some
marshmallows care for one marshmallow I
know
okay so let's Fanny up batch boys
because it's time to party oh yes whoop
whoop Raymond in the gaggle let's go
what are you eating an Italian sub for
breakfast I am but Amy said I should eat
more veggies so I got extra pepper Tina
smart
Julie you need to watch yourself I'm
sorry
cop all right let's everybody just stay
calm here Oh what are you gonna arrest
me for dancing you call that dancing
this is dancing what is happening
[Applause]
dancing over situation confused hello
thank you so much for coming
high five detective pimento didn't want
his funeral to feel stuffy condolences
my man what's going on sir why are you
high five in the bereaved the handshakes
weren't working you couldn't see the
inside of the thumb webbing Gina came up
with an artful solution I'm very sorry
for your loss get some
[Applause]
the system works wait for it wait for it
901 Amy Santiago is officially late for
the first time ever all right let's do
this who's got theories alarmed and go
up all three alarms all with battery
backup come on who wants to take this
seriously
oh she was taken in her sleep that's
what I'm talking about
super dark Boyle but way more plausible
than the Sarge's idiotic alarm clock
theory I bet she tucked herself into bed
too tight and got stuck maybe she fell
into another dimension where she's
interesting it's 9:00 a.m. why is no one
working Amy Santiago is a few minutes
late and we're all trying to guess why I
like to play I'd say she's in line at
the bank this is fun it is fun but
you're all wrong
she clearly slipped through a subway
grate and is having terrible sex with a
mole man there she is Amy where have you
been we've been worried sick do you care
to explain yourself I'm just 70 seconds
late it's not a big deal don't worry
about it Santiago you will tell us and
you will tell us now there's a problem
at the bank
hot damn that meat was good you know
what was your order Charles already gave
us a name and that is the only one we're
gonna use everyone calm down it'll be
fine I have an idea or is everyone
looking at me you just said you had an
idea then you stopped talking oh
goodness I'm very intoxicated I know
your shift is over and you've had a
challenging night but I think I found a
new way to raise morale follow me to the
briefing room
[Music]
what's all this it's an after-work hang
just trying to turn up as it were we got
snacks games decorations chairs
it's chairs cool maybe we can mill
around and small talk about how some of
us are big lying liars who lie all the
time like a bunch of liars Rosa I don't
think that's good party combo maybe we
should just name our favorite sailing
not I'll start the bowline how about
some tunes cool merry-go-round music
yeah John Philip Sousa the Skrillex of
his day come on people hit the dance
floor have a good time why is no one
having a good time I specifically
requested it I'm here I'm here I'm here
you can start the meeting now the
meeting is over you're late you missed
roll call and the tutorial on using the
new car here six years and no matter how
hard I try I still can't get you to
understand the importance of being
punctual if you should just give up and
accept me for who I am no I will break
you right now while you were out being
tardy I was hard to work devising a
special punishment I've crafted an
intricate personal high-five with
everyone in this office except you what
but you hate high-fives yes every minute
of it was hell but it'll be worse for
you
squad dismissed goodbye Diaz snitcher by
Jeffers
[Music]
that's the butt bump right I'll go
double fist bump reverse explosion into
a Pete Townsend strum all right that was
terrible but it's over now and I made it
through goodbye Leonard from Xerox copy
Bulger nezam you someone had a good time
in Paris Oh Kevin and I shared a perfect
week together I feel like I'm floating
on a lost song I wonder why people don't
just break in a song more often I've
been asking you for months if I could
answer the phone like yeah give it a
whirl girl guys I have a great idea for
a prank before Holt comes in I'm gonna
put ink on the podium where he puts his
hands I don't think you'll fall for that
I did how I haven't even opened this yet
- guess it's unrelated
you haven't whole hates pranks this is
gonna backfire a minute yeah fine I'll
tone it down I'll move his podium a foot
to the left what he'll be so angry okay
five inches five three three one one all
right I'll move it a half inch fine it's
your funeral
where's prank ever it's so stupid Holt's
19-minute no yes good morning you guys
that the podium is crazy
how did you pull this off all right this
is the boat now Charles has to think
we're totally sober and we solved his
puzzles so we could yep don't worry
about me I've seen you do enough of
these Harebrained Schemes than aught to
play along if Charles house what's wrong
I'll just put on a coy smile and say no
amazing that is actually perfect all
right now let's hold onto each other for
balance like three totally sober grown
men come here yeah here we go
uh yeah we're nailing this hello Charles
surprise welcome to the party pal
wow this is amazing now we get to the
best part steaks and shots uh-oh more
meat and alcohol or what does that mean
nothing I can't believe that waxing the
floor that we're all stuck in here I've
never seen them do this
they do it once a month we just never
been on the night shift I know it's like
we're being punished we are for going to
Florida I don't listen to so much stuff
you all say well frankly I pitied a lot
of you you look out there and see a
problem I look out there and see an
opportunity I'm gonna slide on that
slippery floor all the way from holds
office to the elevator you're gonna do
the fbp that's right Rosa I'm doing the
full bullpen
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you